I think one has to stay with one's feet
on the ground I think it's too easy to
lose oneself to big ideas expressions
that have many meanings somehow get lost
in this I mean I really often find
myself unable to understand exactly what
it is people are arguing about and I to
tell you the truth I enjoyed the debate
this morning but it's it it will take me
some time yet it will take me some time
I'll show you to bring down the ideas
that were being thrown around to the
workable size so that I can really deal
with them I think we tend to blow things
up and by blowing things up we tend to
become lost in in between you know major
ideologies that we come to see is either
conflicting with one another or being
inconsistent with another with one
another I think we should do - I used
maybe one should use over tear reduce or
reduction so basically to reduce things
to things that we can actually talk
about I think exactly the opposite
exactly the opposite I love big ideas
for a number of reasons first of all I
think that crimes and mistakes can be
committed in the names of big ideas
small ideas practical ideas impractical
ideas I'm not sure that the size of an
idea necessarily matters about certainly
not about regards its truth but I think
that and I and I also think that the the
obligation the universal obligation to
do good and to help others should not
take the place of philosophical or
report or reflection on life in other
words I think that you know philosophers
and non philosophers should both teach
in the prisons so I don't think that I
think that what big eye big ideas give
people a sense of the magnitude of human
life of the grandeur of human life what
I said earlier the tremendousness of
human life and give them a sense that we
are not trivial beings even if we are
cosmically small but we're not trivial
beings and the the attempts to formulate
a worldview you know Musel the Austrian
writer once said wrote that to have a
worldview you have to have a view of the
world
and it seems sort of obvious but he was
right
that there is a kind of scale that big
ideas lift the human spirit up to I
certainly have nothing against the rules
of doing good and the practices of doing
good but I wonder what our self
conception should be in terms of our own
significance and there I think I'm
prepared actually to live with a certain
lack of clarity I guess because there
are things that are not clear and there
are things that can't be made entirely
clear and I wouldn't hold it against a
large concept that it is not completely
clear that doesn't mean I shouldn't
continue working on it but etc etc etc I
think there are certain values that that
are common sense I think this is what we
can all agree on
like I mean doing good being tolerant
you know not kidding
being accepting emphasizing these are
you know common variants that we can all
adapt there's no argument about that I
don't think we can argue about that was
for centuries the ideas of tolerance and
empathy and doing good were not
platitudes and were not common-sense and
in fact if you study the emergence of
toleration in Europe you discover that
what we now take for granted as common
sense actually had to be established by
means of big ideas overthrowing earlier
big ideas
now we enjoy the fruits of those earlier
Big Ideas
you